[Music]
you have worked in two films is that
right with justin timberlake oh two
films with justin yeah yeah oh you call
him justin i call him jt
oh i call him
okay
i call him uh i don't even call him
anything because how close we are
you just sign you don't say anything and
he knows that you're talking about it
okay
were you uh obviously uh you're in that
age range were you a big instinct fan
yes i was who wasn't come on
i had to pretend i wasn't though i mean
i hope he's not watching this but um
don't tell anybody don't tell him um but
yeah i was obsessed with nsync are you
kidding me look at me i'm 26 i was a
perfect age
um but i didn't he wasn't my favorite i
didn't even find him attractive in fact
who was your favorite of the of those
guys of let's see there was ned there
was a chip
you must be talking about some other boy
bands oh i don't know what are their
names
they have a lot of names i liked jc
we got some jc people here yeah where's
jc
can't even say his last name no i mean i
don't know why i haven't seen the guy in
years
you used to see him around he'd just be
hanging around
when i came to hollywood
you
you believe i saw him around really
that sounds kind of threatening actually
or it sounds like somebody's got a
restraining order
oh my god jc won't let you come hear him